now sometimes they will estimate right
bang on the dollar
you like cook done no problems right but
more often than not you'll have lots of
deductions which means you have less
total sorry less taxable become so that
means their estimate of total income tax
is too much right you're like you
thought I had this much but actually
I've deducted all this enough this is
how much you should ask me okay so the
government has accidentally overtaxed
you does that make sense
so how they fix that they give it back
to you in a tax refund so see you might
know right um if the government over tax
you will receive you process all of your
paperwork and that kind of thing and
you'll receive tax that's exactly right
so the whole idea is if I've given to
charity well that's not gonna play
become anymore you shouldn't tax beyond
that that's gone I've never got to use
that one okay
no that's if you're over tax that's if
your deductions are quite great okay but
but think about this for a second right
wenting PAYG tax come from where'd it
come from it came from my income right
this came out of my income but
importantly it came out of my income
from a job so it's my employer which has
the responsibility to say oh well this
is how much we're going to give you and
this is how much goes to the government
now hold on a second we just established
there's other kinds of income that's not
from a job right does this make sense
so suppose I've got like heaps and these
are properties right and all of this
income is coming to me or I might get
income that's not from an employer right
maybe I like driving an uber taxi right
now I should know that's a bad example
cuz Buber is my employer maybe I just
drive my friends around in my Mini
Cooper and I charged the defeat
if I charge them a fee I'm making it
come just make sense should that can
come be taxed or not okay
I mean should the government charge be
tax on that okay now I'm out I'm not
about to start a big discussion about
socialism and its present ones but the
law is if it's income you need to pay
tax on it so here's what happens right
at the UH the reason why I keep
Pharisees because what we do is we
declare our deductions right we declare
hey I didn't keep have all of this money
actually gave it to you know all these
different charities you know Red Cross
etc so don't taxi on that but at the
same time you have to declare I made all
this other income as well okay so for
instance I've done work outside of
school and that has to be declared it
didn't come from my employer it came
from other sources so I've got to say
hey I've made this money so the
government will tax me on it okay now
what happens if I don't do that
that's called tax fraud it's called
taxin right cuz what is like okay so I
collected all this cash back there's no
record of it so I'm just gonna not say
anything about it
and then if the government doesn't know
so they're not gonna tax me but that's
illegal
okay so if I get found out I'll get
heard into jail
okay now think about this for a second
one thing Phoebe if I've got income
right let's suppose I do the right thing
and I declare my income so what happens
to this this is going to go on yes but
the government only knew about this so
I'm making up over tax me by the end of
the
they can under tax means right because
they've only taxed me based on the
income they knew I had and they didn't
even know I had this you can just make
sense so if I've been on the test if I
have been under text and then I do the
right thing I declare everything all of
my income or when you come and my
deductions then I'm not gonna receive a
tax refund am i what's gonna happen
extra tax okay and this is happening
before other people in fact number four
this happens all the time you go through
you do all your paperwork a like oh I
owe them this amount of money and that's
not fun but I'm gonna say I'm just gonna
go understand I mean I I work for public
school I work for the government
um let me finish this paragraph not just
listen to it I really like paid taxes
he's won okay I really I really like
driving on good roads and I really like
being able to take my children to the
hospital for free anytime my life those
are really good things I really like
that my children go to school and I tend
to pay for that directly because it
comes out of my house so you know like
pajamas really obsessed well the
government is just an extension of us
like we want trust me trust me you want
government right this is plenty place
around the world that do not have
government and it doesn't go well for
them okay so this is the whole idea
yeah that's right um there are for
example I think Bruno is an example of
that I got this insanely rich royal
family and so they just don't charge
their citizens income tax well okay yes
so I mean in short yes so for example if
I buy an object right which I
exclusively used for work like this is
like the reason why I have this is so
that I could do my job then that's
actually not really part of my income is
it right it's like to do this job like I
needed this thing so therefore it's like
I couldn't really say how their example
them doing that membership fees right
any job you go into you should be PI the
professional association for all of that
job and that's an important thing Union
fees they're all the same kind of
category all right now I want to make
one final note on this we're really good
at this mathematically all this comes
down to is addition and subtraction
right you add all these things up we're
all then come from and then you subtract
all of these wherever they come from
it's one last thing we want to do you
then have to work out what how much tax
should I pay is your income tax there's
one extra thing ever I mentioned going
to public health care is a new crazy
okay now it's worth pointing out I'm
writing this is an extra thing that you
should write down as well because your
textbook is not that old but it's old
enough that the Medicare levy is
incorrect your textbook will say the
Medicare levy is 1.5 percent it's not
1.5 percent you don't know what it is
now I just want to point that out
because you should know what the real
Medicare levy is but obviously because
the textbook was written with 1.5
percent in mind when you're calculating
you'll use 1.5 okay
the important thing is like just pay
attention we'll get a question and see
what it says if you're in an assessment
if it's you know you see this is that's
what I'm actually yeah like I've taught
this before when we were back in if they
want an m2 right please don't just throw
around numbers tell me what those are
say Medicare levy and then say you 0.02
times whatever okay or 2% cuz your
calculator can do that ok if you say
what everything is then you won't go
okay so when you get to the Medicare
levy questions that you'll see it's on
your taxable income okay so it's not on
total income we're always taxing on
despite which is why we call it tax and
wake up